- Oo, this place is dope Drew.
Good call getting a place
so close to Bonaroo, my man.
- Oh yeah, man, all the
drugs, music, and food
a growing boy needs.
- Speaking of, Drew.
- [Both] Shrooms, shrooms,
shrooms, shrooms, shrooms.
(upbeat music)
(laughing)
- Bonaroo!
♪ We get real crazy ♪
(upbeat music, cheering)
(squirting)
(upbeat music)
♪ We get real crazy ♪
- We love you!
- We love you, man.
- Thank you for the water.
- Okay, it's pizza and
you haven't paid me
but you can have it for
free, just let me go, okay?
I've got to get out of here.
(groans)
God.
- Excuse me, sorry, excuse me.
(knocking)
Come on, Drew, I
got to pee, man.
- Sorry, dude, I made a
real stinky mess in there.
- Fine.
Oh my God, oh.
- Not answering their phones.
- Where the hell are those guys?
- Losers missed the
entire festival.
- Happy Bonaroo, guys!
- Happy 'Roo!
- You guys know you
never actually made it
into Bonaroo, right?
- They do this every year.
- This band sucks.